hello everyone and welcome to this
rather special video so first of all I
want to acknowledge this channel has
been quiet for a couple of weeks
the first reason for that is that I am
now in a new house pixel girl and I
moved and that obviously sort of was
quite stressful but secondly I have been
traveling a lot to this past month
getting footage for future science
videos some of which are quite close to
completion and others are going to be
released much further down the line but
there's some really exciting stuff
coming thank you for your patience this
video however is something completely
different this video is going to be
about the theoretical side of YouTube
and what I mean by that is how the
platform has evolved over time how the
metter has shifted how YouTube and
society interact with each other this is
a topic that I've alluded to in previous
videos and of my podcast but I wanted to
do this video because I had access to a
really interesting guy this is Chris
Stowe Colt Walker who's a journalist
who's just published a book last week
called youtubers which is about the
multi-faceted nature of this website and
its interactions with its society if
you're interested by the way there'll be
a link to be booked in we do we do now
this isn't a sponsored video at all in
fact this is actually the opposite I
came to him and asked if we could do a
video talking about the subject because
he more than probably anyone else on the
planet really understands the
multi-faceted nature of YouTube and
where it's going so this is gonna be
totally different to one of my normal
videos this is basically an extended
discussion between me and Chris on the
subject of YouTube did you find that
interesting then please do stick around
let me know what you think in the
comments because I'd love this to spark
a discussion between me and the audience
because that's what as partly what makes
this website so special if you are here
expecting a science video then that's
not going to be this I will be back very
soon with another one of those so thank
you for watching up to this path but
yeah bye that said if you're still
watching the video then I hope you
enjoyed this discussion and if you find
this interesting then do consider
checking Chris's book out enjoy for
people who have stumble across this
video and want to know more about the
book specifically what's it about what's
the compromise it is a vain attempt to
summarize 14 years of YouTube in 352
pages I think is probably the best way
to describe I know it's it's about
it's about the platform the creators on
it the different associated industries
that have come out as a result of it its
impact on society its impact on the
media because changing an awful lot and
where we might go in the future
with this weird thing so who is it aimed
at so in this is the interesting thing
and I think we probably talked about us
before in terms of the differing
audiences so it was initially aimed
purely at hardcore YouTube fans and
creators and things like that my
publisher quite rightly says that's
really interesting but there's a large
audience that maybe want to know more
about this and so it kind of zoomed out
a little bit more so while it's useful
for people's parents and grandparents to
know about this thing there's still
plenty of stuff in there that will let
even the most hardcore YouTube
aficionados hopefully learn something
yeah you know I've read I actually
devoured it I don't think I've ever read
a book as quickly as this apartment
maybe the great gatsby it was super
interesting as a creator to have
somebody come at it from an analytical
perspective and we've talked about this
video that there is a certain lack of
not necessarily self-awareness but on
YouTube and off YouTube people don't
really seem to take the format seriously
you know it is a frivolity seemingly in
the minds of people but that I think as
we talked about before is the age
difference right yeah exactly it is and
this is part of the issue that I have as
a working journalist who has been trying
to cover this stuff for 5 6 7 years is
that I will suggest an idea something
massive is happening on YouTube or
YouTube is having a massive cultural
impact and I will email my editor and
say we really need to be covering this
and then they will come back and say
well I'm a 50-year old man I don't care
about this I watch the news at 6 o'clock
at night every day on TV and that's it I
maybe watch Netflix but I have no real
interest in new media as it's many many
yes that the reach of the 6 o'clock news
at night is probably comparable to the
very top tier of YouTube channel this is
a perfect example in the book where
after the ksi Logan Paul fight I went on
BBC Breakfast TV the day after and that
seemed by an average of like 1.5 million
people every morning now the KS Iloka
bull fight was seen by like yeah I mean
the number of pirate streams was like at
least 1/2 million so yeah
the disparate sort of scale of this is
ridiculous and I don't understand how
you get that across I think you know
we've talked to us before that we do
need to have a generational change on
years when the people who grew up on
YouTube become that you can make the
decisions in traditional media yeah
that's it's gonna change so so you know
you mentioned that you're a journalist
who covers this as part of your day job
who-who did you interview as part of
this book so it's basically the
culmination of sort of years of
reporting so yeah there's things in
there from big names like ksi Emma
blackery
people like that the green brothers in
there because I've spoken to them for
wire before and it's kind of built
around several scenes as well so loads
of people I've interacted with there's
probably more than 100 interviewees in
both people in front of the camera and
behind the camera a lot of agents Sarah
Michael who is massive of Hannah Hart's
agent Lilly Singh's agent and people who
are kind of in creating MCM Zoar new
talent agencies as well because I kind
of wanted it's an impossible task and
you know I'm fully aware that there are
gaps in this but it's an attempt to try
and get across as best as possible the
scale and the scope of this thing well
it's like I said in my written review
for this that it's like blind men
touching another thing yeah you know it
nobody no single description this thing
was perspective it can do justice to you
too because what what the website is is
totally different to parents to young
people to broadcasters to Jimmy Kimmel
yeah but but the interesting thing is
that while you can't get the elephant in
the totality what we've had up till now
particularly in terms of mainstream
press coverage is very reductive it is
what has low
Inbal done what has Jay Paul done what
is the latest scandal whereas this is an
attempt to try and round out that view a
little bit because there are only a
handful of journalists who are actually
covering this stuff with the respect
that it deserves and you have Amelia
Tate in the UK you have Taylor wrens and
Jews or Alexandra in the US and so this
is just an attempt really to try and
give a more accurate view of what this
thing is this isn't a way then almost
like a field diary you know you going
out into the field and talking to
youtubers yet to report back to all the
other people in the sector yeah and also
you know people who kind of are on the
periphery of YouTube so there's an
example there the day after the brexit
though in 2016 I went down to Brighton
and watched a bunch of all people talk
about what they thought YouTube was as a
way of marketing their business and it
was awful like it was ridiculous but
that's in there is like a comic relief
thing to show this generational gap that
we talked about basically so yeah it's
um it is a real challenge to get across
all of this site but I think that it's
important that someone starts that
conversation first
yes ever done this really in it and 14
years in because something that you do
talk about in the book is the the fact
that youtubers have very real life
consequences so there was the murder of
Chris Nima grooming christina grimmie
yeah and the terrorist I guess you could
call them terrorist attacks on the
YouTube page q people rocking on the air
trying to change the policy you know the
YouTube has a really dark side that even
that seems to be poorly represented in
mainstream media yeah well because they
they basically don't understand it and I
find it alarming given the power that
this site has I mean I I go through
these numbers all the time and you know
them and everybody else know something
but 1.9 billion monthly users think
about the world's population think about
the fact that half of them don't have
internet access think about the fact
that China isn't really a market yeah
and so suddenly you're looking at
basically the entire in
that connected world is on YouTube and
it does have real-life experiences it
bleeds over there's this idea I suppose
that everything that happens on YouTube
is online only and we still want to like
partition it in its own little weird box
and it does a disservice to what this
platform it's I think so that does bring
something out they wanted to talk about
a girl online did you try to purchase
the weather I did not because there's no
real reason to I don't think she's seen
certainly the UK community as like
almost a figurehead of the YouTube UK
community yeah well I don't I don't want
to start beef I don't get any drama I
don't be on drama alert but I do think
that she represents a different type of
YouTube and I think particularly in the
mainstream press
she is massively successful says Alf Ian
and it's great that they're doing that
and eight is Ed creatives is a really
interesting development in terms of how
you build out a staff but I also think
that she almost represents like a
previous generation of YouTube and I
think that she's grasped that a bit too
readily by the mainstream media to try
and represent what YouTube is I mean you
look at you know his subscription
numbers and things like that and and
have used and they are going down more I
think than the average person's also
yeah and that's the things from his
perspective an active youtuber your
number of subscribers doesn't mean earth
yeah as far as that like I think some
advertisers don't know this you know
appetizers you know what they're talking
about know that its views yeah how
typical up that counts see you know she
that was I did wonder if that was white
because she is in many ways part of the
old guard there are plenty of people
like what the buck show yeah other
example who have massive popularity on
the website but then because
subscriptions don't need to be renewed
like for example
twitch yes it's very unrepresentative
and this and this is a thing by
necessity I have to mention subscribers
basically because
the mainstream audience still recognizes
that symmetric that they understand yeah
but in there there is a chunk talking
about actually we talk about subscribers
but you have 16 year old kids who you
know subscribe to zoella when they were
that age you know 10 13 years later
they're now parents with kids so they
don't have time to yeah
is there a historical precedent for the
YouTube industry so that's the question
I asked literally everybody that haven't
we and nobody gives me a good answer
um I think probably there is in terms of
the early days of Hollywood in that you
think about it and yeah I used to love
silent films and so you'd have like
Charlie Chaplin and Fatty Arbuckle and
people like that who would literally
make in these very small films on a
shoestring budget running around doing
everything themselves and then suddenly
you had the consolidation you have
things like the United Artists coming
around and everybody teams up as a
production firm and so I think and then
with contracts into particular studio
integrated yeah exactly and so now
everything is happening like that and
and so we had like the yeah it gave me
another theory that I haven't really
fleshed out but is one I think about a
lot it keeps me awake at night because
this is what I do with YouTube is we had
that first wave of an attempt at
business and I think of it a bit like a
tide in terms of like the early MGM's
like it was people realized oh there's
money in this space I'm gonna come in
and ruin everything essentially yeah
leave terribly and and the model didn't
work and you look at all the MGM's that
have gone to the wall and the massive
100 million dollar plus purchases yeah
and and they failed and so they went
away like the tide and we had a little
bit more of sort of you know creator
entrepreneurial lead YouTube for a bit
and then now we're seeing an awful lot
of consolidation a lot of mergers and
acquisitions on the business side and a
lot of traditional media companies
coming in and buying up the properties
that those individual creator
entrepreneurs
made so by comparison then to the old
Hollywood system does that mean then
that in the future do you think we'll
see more legislation coming in to
prevent monopolies either from issue
itself or from governments that's a good
question I don't know I mean because
that was what happened in the Georgia in
the CR industry right it was 47
something yeah yeah it was breaking up
the studios preventing them from owning
every part of distribution production
marketing I mean I think that YouTube as
a company is so hands off on that stuff
that I can't imagine them doing it and
that's but would it not but would a
monopoly on the website not diminish the
profit for YouTube in the competition on
the website would improve viewership it
would improve the money that's going
into the I think it would but I think
that the opportunity for expansion is
still so great in that there are
untapped viewers that they wouldn't get
to the point where they have to yeah
basically I see okay so there's a nice
an imperfect analogy but for the moment
yeah it does feel like it's quite a
prayer yeah in that you have people new
setting up things and some of them fail
some of them really succeed and become
you know in that firmament of Hollywood
celebrities and they become mainstream
and then you have people who are better
than others you managed to sort of grab
more of that stuff and you have you know
businessmen and women coming in saying
well actually we can help you expand in
this way but you have to maybe
compromise your creative vision and so
that's why we get endless sequels that's
why we get all these stupid videos that
are all asone basically and also you do
notice that that you have almost
incubators now for channels you get I've
noticed that some of the study Cheevers
for example suddenly explode and
viewership and in the subscribers
because they can notice by somebody at a
company and they've had money invested
in yeah it's a smart bet isn't it I mean
if you take the hypothesis which I
strong stress that you should which is
that this is a massive modern media
monolith that it is replacing TV and
it's probably gonna replace film at some
point and you think well if I want to
make money then it makes sense for me to
just continue to follow the money
basically
so you just to bring you back on up him
you you think that YouTube is eventually
going to replace film yeah I'm so i I -
well I mean yeah why not
let's make bold predictions know I think
Edie's becoming a respected medium and I
think that a lot of when I talk to
creators a lot of them are getting bored
of doing the same 1015 minute stuff and
they are trying to be a bit more
expansionist in terms of what they do so
go longer like shingles and yeah Shane
Dawson you know Logan Paul's terrible
conspiracy theory thing there are
craters that I've spoken to who said
that they are planning to do films film
length stuff on YouTube then the next
year or so because those obviously give
me a continual groundswell of there's
gonna be new talent coming in that wants
to do the stuff that they watch yeah so
would that mean that the older craters
gonna stay on YouTube is it going to be
migration to a new service because
that's the other thing we should point
out as you mentioned in the book there's
a history of online video yeah there are
no competitors to you if if Amazon
actually decides to pay attention to
twitch the an if twitch starts doing
more IRL streams then potentially that
something Facebook watchers just kind of
died a slow death yeah it didn't really
work you know tick tock is building its
own thing but it's very different
never
yeah except and so I mean yeah like it's
it's YouTube's game to lose I think and
you know some of the decisions that they
make may may make that more likely but I
mean that it's not going away it's the
thing it's been here 14 years it's it's
and with no competitors yeah I mean do
you do you think there will ever be is
it even possible for a competitor for
you
yeah I don't see why you would I mean
people I get press releases about you
know blockchain based video platforms
and things that will
would create as better all the time and
you look at Vimeo which has kind of
stuck around but is very much in the
yeah exactly and and and I think there's
there's space to do something more
culturally interesting and you can carve
out a niche in the online video space by
being a platform that isn't so
all-encompassing that doesn't have
people like you and people like zoella
and people like logan paul on the same
platform i think that you you know you
can get sub sections of that but in
terms of replacing the whole thing and
becoming absolutely massive no difficult
thing is that I've noticed no youtubers
that the channels that the recent
channels which are incredibly successful
are the ones that are very specialized
yeah you know tears there's an example I
like to give from the edgy community of
this it's just it's thing does it very
well but that's it you know and you know
and I should point out bloody love tears
I'm not putting that as negative example
but you the fact that yeah as a platform
the breadth is enormous super house yeah
that there wouldn't be a competitor
because no platform will seek to be as
broad a specialization is key and you
don't need to I mean is the quote in
control is from Hank or John Green who
said that year he goes to VidCon now and
he will walk past people who have like
two million subscribers or X million
views every month and he won't know who
on earth they are because this this
platform is so big it's like he said I
think at the end of 2018 there were was
it four thousand channels with more than
a million subscribers and more than ten
million subscribers I can't remember
which I think you you look at that and
you think all these people are major
celebrities and and they could be doing
anything from cooking to to gain me
after gaming to energy nothing do you
think that YouTube is a net positive
world
it depends on what day it is to be
honest look it's it's given people the
opportunity to enter the creative
industry who would otherwise not had the
chance it's been massively interesting
and important in terms of
democratization
but along with that there is a whole
mess of societal stuff which we haven't
got a handle on and which we don't yet
know the answers to there are people
doing research right now at the
University of Westminster about burnout
and the impact of that I'm really
concerned about what happens when you
are a kid who is 4 years old and instead
of holding a hairbrush in front of the
mirror and doing a song you film it and
then that's up there forever more I'm
worried about what happens when you
become famous that Charlie McDonnell
example is perfect so you become famous
at 16 and it's kind of not necessarily
the person that you actually truly are
but it's a little bit his quote was the
line that I think stuck with me the most
actually from the whole book made that
mask when I was 14 and it doesn't fit
yeah and that's that's I say this quite
a lot to people because it's I don't
want to be like the old man shouts a
mean thing but like that is this year's
burnout discussion I think is what
happens when you grow out of being the
person that you are and your audience is
so committed and so great and the stakes
are so high that you feel beholdin
almost - yeah to be the person that you
are and not and actually it was a really
interesting question
because I put out a thing about this and
then Trenton Lee who is doing some
research here in London about burnout
it's really interesting he he asked
whether or not that's actually just the
thing that's relate to YouTube or
whether that's a wider societal thing
where as you grow up as like a terrible
team years now whether or not we're also
gonna have to add in the fact that you
have to reckon with the idea of
reinventing and stepping away from your
digital self level scary doesn't it is
again rinse homework it's incredible to
me that it's taken this long for the
like this to come out about it you know
it's one of the major to me obviously
I'm biased because I am a YouTube when I
consume a lot of YouTube but one of the
kind key digital pillars in the temple
of the internet yeah and you know so
that so little is understood about it by
the general public
well it's because so I am 29 going on 30
and so I grew up and 2007/2008 stuff
like that I was watching Bo Burnham and
wheezywaiter and people like that and
loving it and I've grown up with this
platform if you were even slightly older
than me if you were two three five years
older than me you didn't have that sort
of digital native thing YouTube wasn't
necessarily a formative experience for
you as it was for me so all of the
people who are covering this in the
journalism world are sort of my age or
younger and it's not the youngest you
deposited yeah so that's kind of partly
why it's not being a case is that up
until now everybody who was professed to
have an opinion about this has been an
old person I didn't really use the
platform I think
[Music]
one that I actually really love is lofty
pursuits which is a boiled sweet making
channel the guy is based in Florida and
he has this shot basically and he goes
through how he makes these sweets using
traditional methods and things like that
and it's kind of a little bit like ASMR
in a weird way because just relaxing yes
and I interviewed him it didn't really
make into the book much of it but it was
interesting because he said that he's
watch time is absolutely crazy because
it starts late at night as people are
going to sleep and they just fall asleep
and they just autoplay through the night
so he's like it's great I mean I'm
making this money I'm getting subliminal
advertising because they're asleep and
they're probably hearing some of them
yeah but he was a bit like should I be
concerned that I am sending people to
sleep really mess with people with that
well I said that's an equal full of ASMR
relation is have you seen the IKEA ASMR
I know it's got now let's take a look at
the desk
it's your standard-issue dorm provided
desk this is the super flexible Jean
geode LED work lamp it's slim
lightweight and easy to move around you
know it's interesting that's the
subculture that people kind of poaching
because I'd be interested to see if
there are other subcultures and very
good ASMR is pretty weird yeah I mean I
love it but it's it's weird
yeah you know if people could find some
undiscovered gem of YouTube this is
advertising gold well I mean you had and
you have a s are a minute and then like
a year or so before that you had like
mukbang and things like that so I don't
know if these these things tend to come
from nowhere and what's interesting is
and this kind of goes to the idea of the
maturity is that if someone finds a
winning formula or a winning former a
video everybody seems to do it now which
is life cycle seems to shrink yeah the
the before trends would last for
really long time now it's over and done
with a couple of days past attention
span isn't and it's also just the scale
of it if you have you know hundreds of
thousands of craters putting out the
same thing viewers get sick a bit
quicker
I think yeah like you know compare
something like the Harlem shake for
exact yeah it felt like it was over
another than a week it was like a weird
fever really
[Music]
really happened it's still on that and
that you know presumably those videos
the the view grass will be fascinating
yeah well I mean imagine what what
happens if you're an alien that comes to
this planet and just says what on earth
is that about why look yeah why are they
dancing in their offices and then yeah
we kind of think about that as a you
know it's what only been like five years
remove now from from that if that it's
on screen yeah again
making people anything and looking back
at it you say it's like a fever dream
like these things just capture the
zeitgeist and then disappear and burn
out so well I would I'd love it and
someone in the comments please tell me
if this is actually already exist I
would love something like a visual
representation of what is trending on eg
but I'm so not the YouTube trending tab
as in a network of kind of tags the rise
and fall and you're gonna have stuff
like gaming that's always going to be
there yeah every now and again you'll
get something like hot hashtag Harlem
shake which just erupts and then you
check it the next day and it's shrunk
and it's shrunken it shrunk and shrunk
and that visual representation of for an
alien's benefit say what media are the
humans consuming today that would be the
front page of what human consciousness
that will also be great for me as a
journalist I find it please if it
doesn't exist
somebody please code back yeah please
who's better at coding than me oh don't
even say you know about that me if you
found this chat interesting which I hope
you did this book is basically more the
same yeah I think really is a very
comprehensive as comprehensive as it's
possible for one account to be
representation of what it is like to go
in the inside of YouTube and I just I
really hope it does well I hope that
this sparked people to understand us a
lot better than you know it's almost
like an anthropological study of
vloggers of youtubers in general so yeah
you know if check it out there'll be a
link down there in the description if
you do want to check it out and thank
you so much for having a chat thank you
miss or what your social to be down
there as well Brooke Tiffany you're on
everything oh yeah a bar from YouTube
weirdly
thanks very much for watching have a
youtube channel because to it my god can
you imagine that's true yeah it's a lot